everybody except you know Chuck there's
a complaint with air time
not really it's down right now to try me
first and foremost I'm an investor at
the hundred million dollar round but you
guys know me well enough that I don't
pimp put my investments the reason I'm
making the video is I have a feeling a
feeling that feels really quite nice it
feels very Twitter two thousand six and
seven to me right now the air time
experience and played around for a
couple hours is quite incredible now
it's not scalable which is why I love it
the reason I had some success on Twitter
is because I'm obsessed with scaling the
non-scalable when you really get your
hands dirty get the blood underneath
your fingernails that one-on-one
marketing that to me is what I'm
obsessed about that's a Thank You
economy that's what I talk about that's
the way she feel about your time
actually creates that if you love people
discovery and clearly I do which is why
I invested in you long ago and one and
all these things and obsessed with
highlight when it launched this is an
incredible people discovery tool but
it's using your Facebook Connect so it's
around the subject of the friends and so
the people have been meeting have been
people I know and or kind of know so
that's quite incredible but more
importantly with Twitter what made that
so unbelievable is people getting to
know each other and follow each other
engaging but you did that behind the
written word with video you can't be a
douchebag and that's a very big factor
here it's kind of hard to be jerky or
trying to sell like a hillbilly gym
finger to somebody when it's face to
face you that differently
when you can see the person that when
Twitter when you're writing I think air
time for the people that really care who
want to scale relationships who like to
network in a non Gucci way who
appreciate people appreciating their
work or common interests are gonna love
this platform and I'm gonna try to
hustle a whole lot neat I don't know
crapload to do and I Paulo
yes man but I'm going to struggle -
flight there was about to do lot of
stuff on my Wi-Fi I mean your timing
with [ __ ]